in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions Zak and Aaron are with
us hey how are you hey
welcome welcome where are you guys from
we're from Nashville right here
neighbors then that's right all right
very fun so you traveled a whole few
minutes yes you're that free screen
that's cool we're glad you're here how
much have you paid off
we paid off two hundred and sixty
thousand dollars Wow love it and how
long did that take five years and nine
months five years nine months making
what kind of money we started that
80,000 and we ended at 230,000 what do
you guys do for a living I'm a dentist
and I'm I'm not the breadwinner right
now I'm doing a medical residency so
well I have a some income but mostly are
okay Wow well congratulations well
you're probably making 150 residency
aren't you yeah they pay us better than
they used to that's cool very good
all right so great income and I'm
guessing this with student loans then
yes it was all student loans Wow
so odd yes five years worth yes and now
you cash flowing his medical school in
and we are well I'm done with medical
schools actually get so fortunately I'm
at the point now where they so the way
around now they thank you rather than
you pay them that's kind of indentured
servitude okay so we broke through the
the plane on that ready to go there
congratulations you guys so what
happened five years of nine months ago I
guess you got out of school yes I
graduated from dental school and I think
I've always had a little bit of your
mindset and but I didn't know of you yet
so when we started we actually didn't
get on the plan until about a year and a
half into that five years and nine
months but um I just I didn't like the
way it felt I felt like I was at the
bottom of a mountain
I wanted to I wanted to get it out of
the way so I could do other things
besides worry about our debt you know
how long have y'all been married five
and a half years oh right about that
happened about that so you got married
you got out of then I'll school and
you're looking at this mountain the debt
you okay we got to start working on this
correct and at that time you were in med
school I guess right I had one more year
left in school okay all right very cool
well congratulations you guys it is a
huge mountain that's a lot now you make
good money but you paid off a lot yes a
lot and you weren't making this kind of
money all along either no like you said
you started at 80 yes and you've
averaged over 50 a year so that's pretty
and pretty incredible average pretty
cool how's it feel how's it feel it
feels great yeah I mean I think it
honestly you know hasn't quite set in
yet because I think you get to a point
where early on it's hard and like Aaron
was saying it emotionally feels like a
mountain and when you're in school that
long and not making any money that
figure sort of becomes imaginary and not
real and so I think a lot of people it's
easy for them to come out and that
number just doesn't exist and so they
just sort of start and that's their
baseline and they never really get out
of it and so we didn't want to sort of
fall into that pattern and then you know
once you you do you see that traction it
takes a little while to see that it
feels good and so now we've sort of set
the good habits and it's been easy just
to maintain those and now we're sort of
realizing that we're going to be able to
transition that cash flow into things
that are really important long-term we
have two young kids and so for the
future exactly not realizing that wow
now you know we can talk about how how
do we want to say for their futures and
how do we want to give them a better
house to live in and and things like
that that you know you didn't even think
about you know five years and nine
months ago yeah well way to go you guys
it's got to feel cool now you got some
other med school students out there
dental students out there listening yeah
so you know
it's it's a tough spot to be in and and
my hope is that as things move forward
with medical education the whole system
changes because I think it's a system
that's not going to be sustainable the
way it's going the way that you know
we're getting in higher and higher debt
and our compensation isn't necessarily
rising to match that but that being said
I think it's still a great profession I
would encourage people who are
passionate about that to go into it and
when you get out don't don't give up but
if they're sitting there looking like
you were five years and nine months at
the bottom of that mountain tell them
the secret Aaron what did you all do I
think it's important to just make sure
you keep the big picture in mind you're
not getting out of debt just to get out
of debt you're getting out of debt so
that you can pay for your kids college
and so that you can do things like maybe
pay for somebody else's kids college one
day I think that's that for me was was
the most important thing I couldn't just
look to a month from now I had to say
okay why am I really doing this and that
kept me going and I think it's important
you know five years and nine months is a
long time and with any big goal sort of
having intermittent things that sort of
refresh your passion and emotion to do
things it's easy to get burned out and
we weren't gung-ho 100% of that time but
I think Aaron was really good about it I
mean she downloaded the iHeartRadio app
and I promise every night when we're
washing dishes or the kids getting a
bath
it's on and so you're hearing these
stories night in and night out that you
know sort of remind you and encourage
you and have a group mentality and
surrounding yourself with you know
things that are going to keep you
motivated yeah very cool well
congratulations you guys so proud of you
very very well done
Zak and Aaron from Nashville two hundred
and sixty thousand dollars paid off that
beat dental school and some other five
years and nine months started all this
process at eighty thousand now making
two thirty count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
you guys
very very well done love it love it love
it